I love that message about not starting
the day with email and certain at 1030
or 11 o'clock what then do you recommend
that entrepreneurs do start their day
with well I'll give you a very simple
process I was teaching this to someone
in Japan yesterday actually a very large
number of people in Japan yesterday and
it varies it starts with a piece of
paper and you a piece of paper and a pen
or pencil will make you rich and we
won't go into goal-setting it's a whole
separate process but make a list of
everything that you have to do tomorrow
the best time to make your list is the
night before if you make a list of your
whole day for tomorrow your subconscious
will work on your list overnight and
you'll wake up in the morning with ideas
and insights that are sometimes quite
amazing so you make a list and then you
look at the list and you ask this simple
question if I could only do one thing on
this list before I was called out of
town for a month which one task what I
want to be sure to get completed and put
a circle around that your list now when
you get up in the morning whatever time
you start and that's a very interesting
point wealthy people start by to get up
in the morning my 6am poor people get up
at seven or afterwards wealthy people
get up earlier for people get up later
real simple so if you're getting up
around seven o'clock you're always going
to be poor for the simple reason by the
time you get started the day's half
finished and now you check in your email
and you're talking to your friends and
then it's lunch time and coffee timing
and spam time and everything else get up
at six o'clock and you develop a ritual
get up exercise then sit plan your day
get organized and start to hit it at
eight o'clock and the first thing you do
is you start on your most important task
and then you concentrate single mind to
be on that task you do not turn on your
email you do not turn on your telephone
you don't do anything except that one
task and you just do this one task until
it's completed now you've already agreed
with yourself in the world that there is
nothing more valuable in the world than
you could do than this one task so do
this and if you develop a habit of
getting up in the morning and started
and completing your most important task
it will transfer
your life it's one of the most
incredible productivity habits ever
discovered and every person who
discovers it they see their income their
productivity their performance and their
satisfaction just explode it's very
simple the question is do you have the
discipline do you have the self-control
the willpower to start and complete your
most important task if you if you don't
have it you can develop with practice if
you develop with practice it soon
becomes easy and automatic and if you
just do this your productivity will
double the first day